Speaker 1: We know that Trump supporters
are willing to commit great acts of heinous
violence in the name of Trump. How do we know
that? Because they did it on January six, 2021,
and hundreds of their cases are still being
adjudicated and sentences are being handed out. So
immediately the concern has been are they going to
riot tomorrow if Trump is arrested? Are they going
to riot? Are they going to protest? Trump calling
for them to protest, protest, protest. Trump
saying it is time. It is time to, quote, take our
nation back when his followers try to take things,
it often gets very, very ugly. Business Insider
reporting. Trump issued a siren call for his
supporters to protest and take our nation back.
He. Made the call after claiming without evidence
that he will be arrested Tuesday. His lawyers
said they have no knowledge of the impending
arrest. And increasingly, there is this question
as to whether they will become violent. Will they
become violent? The Manhattan district attorney
says, and this is weirdly cut off and I apologize.
That attempts to intimidate his office will not be
tolerated. After Donald Trump calls for protest,
Alvin Bragg sought to reassure staffers that
they will indeed be safe. Here is my thought
on this. I am maintaining cautious optimism that
Trump's followers won't riot if he's arrested,
at least not in New York City. They may riot
somewhere, but at least not in New York City. And
here's a couple of different logistical things.
New York City is not a hotbed for Trump support,
particularly not Manhattan, where presumably this
arrest and indictment will take will take place.
Many of these folks would have to go to Manhattan
in order to riot in Manhattan, the site of Trump's
arrest if it happens there. And quite frankly,
it's kind of expensive to get over those bridges.
And next thing you know, they'll be paying,
what, 15 bucks to come into the city and then
70 bucks to park during the day. And I'm hoping,
quite frankly, this may be naive, but I'm hoping
that the financial element of this will be a
deterrent for them to come and actually protest
and become violent in Manhattan. So, first of
all, hopefully that doesn't happen and hopefully
it doesn't happen at all. Now, that being said, it
is possible that they will do something. They may
go to Mar a Lago as a as a sign of support. And
so hopefully like that wouldn't get violent. But
of course, going to Mar a Lago and Trump's in New
York for the arrest, I don't know is that maybe
it's hard to know what will sort of pacify these
folks. Maybe they will go to Washington, D.C.. Not
completely clear to me, but I think at this point
I don't have too much to say other than I hope and
I'm cautiously optimistic that there will not be
another horrifying anti-American, anti-democratic,
anti law and order day of rioting like there was
on January six, 2021. Let me know in the comments
on Instagram. On YouTube. Send an email info at
David Pakman dot com. Do you expect rioting if
Trump is arrested? And if it happens, will MAGA
just say it wasn't them, it was BLM or some other
trope that they'll pull out the way they did
on January six? Let me know what you think.